okay so this happened if you're seeing
this video that means at least I have
access to my account again but I can't
seem to delete anything I can't delete
fav O's post but if you're seeing this
at least I can post you know I don't I
don't need this I don't need a stalker
right now I don't I'm trying to move my
life forward a little bit and look look
at this we've got like weird but
strangely erotic mm-hmm Fabo is
strangely erotic apparently I haven't
even had a date in almost three years
but my stalker is hot great or this one
or check us out
I think it's Nick wearing a week mmm-hmm
like okay so YouTube era and everything
is a conspiracy theory now so I'm going
to guard my phone we'd call the police
but Listeria island doesn't have police
I'm supposed to be promoting my online
courses not scouring Facebook for like
how to delete settings but you know I'm
just gonna proceed I'm gonna keep going
when life throws you lemons you make
what margaritas or something you did
when you do work with the lemons okay so
500 is a lemon I'm just going to keep
moving somehow maybe it'll give me
inspiration it's nice being here I love
Leviathan I have you all company if you
like the videos I make please do share
them I'm making a big push as you've
noticed trying to get my online courses
selling because people really like them
and they seem good for people and it's
good for me so if you like what I post
please do share it means a lot so on
with the show regardless of weird
stalker dudes thanks for watching
[Music]